Julie: Hello YouTubers
I'm here at the World Economic forum and I
have one piece of advice and that is exercise,
but exercise three things.
First of all, if you are lucky enough to live
somewhere in the world where you can vote,
exercise you right to vote.
Because that is one of the most important
things we can do to improve our global citizenship.
Second thing is exercise kindness.
Certainly on a day to day basis there's something
that each of us can do to exhibit kindness,
whether it's locally or globally.
And lastly, just exercise.
All of us at CDC know that that is the most
important thing you can do to protect your
health.
So have fun and exercise.
Thank You